[Music]
so how do we water that fertile ground
because I firmly believe that it exists
and I see people from the left on the
left is gone bonkers I'm moving to the
center
I see people saying I don't like this
authoritarian right I move into the
center and I think there is incredible
fertile ground for sex but is this is
this a new political movement is this a
political party it doesn't have to be
everything at once it could have to be a
social movement and they and a political
movement a human movement now I I
consider myself libertarian classic
liberal better I have my belief and I I
kind of would characterize myself as an
anti progressive meaning you can't the
libertarians who say no you just got to
stop everything right now we you can't
it's it's been a hundred years to get
here
right these are the guys that argue
about lights and driver's licenses and a
job it's like stop it stop it
yeah yes can we get there someday yes
but we have to do it in the reverse this
is this is a huge building that we have
to take apart without scaring everyone
and without everything the society
collapsing a lot of people are dependent
on this now slowly dismantle and reverse
okay
Penn is you know and an ad heart I mean
a I can't think of the word now you know
he's a magician
ya know I'm an anarchist right and if
the entire kiss really I mean I think of
him as more of like just a pure
libertarian but if there's a fine line
he's a miraculous he will say I'm an
anarchist okay you know he's not really
right but that's where his heart lives
just let's go come on no rules let's go
right the magician yeah so and we were
talking about it and I said you know we
disagree on a lot of stuff and he said
no Blaine this is so important no we
actually don't you and I probably have a
good 30 years of life left in us you
and I could work together and walk down
the line for 30 years dismantling this
stuff before we have our first argument
there's so much easy stuff that we all
agree on that's what we have to focus on
but that's not what drives money and
clicks it's these big things why don't
we work on these first let's let's come
together that's a pretty basic principle
so what are some of those things that we
could slowly untie so if you want the
government to actually be smaller if you
want people to have more individual
liberty a little more money in their
pocket a little more control over their
lives what are the things that you can
take without destroying the system
because now I sense there's people on
both sides that want the whole system to
blow up and I am for all its fault it's
a pretty damn good system I am convinced
that if we could find a way to restate
the Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution we would be in almost full
agreement with people it just seems like
old language now yeah but if I could say
to you look there are things that you
high and everybody watching us are all
going to agree on I can wake them up in
the dead of night and say hey should man
man man shouldn't be picked up in the
middle of night mean enslaved without
charges right I know okay everybody is
the same right I mean it's what you
create afterwards but when you're born
every baby is exactly the same right yes
let me go back to sleep
that's self-evident yeah we find certain
things to be self-evident okay life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness we
all agree on that now First Amendment I
agree that the press should be free with
that freedom comes responsibility but
that's their job not the government's
job they must try to be responsible
freedom of speech freedom of assembly
freedom to defend yourself this one
would be a little harder because there
are a lot of people are against guns but
if you state it this way where do laws
come from if somebody
as the government then we have to have
another remedial conversation who gives
the government power and how can I how
if I don't have the right would it be
right if I moved into a neighborhood and
somebody down the street was doing all
these just making tons of money and I
got all the neighbors to get together
and I said you know what he's got too
much I love his car don't you guys love
his car yes
shouldn't we have a bit of his cars be
able to take his car one day a week he
can have it one day a week no I appoint
you I'm going to give you this badge
you'll go over and tell him why is it
wrong because the people in the
neighborhood don't have the right
themselves to take it you can't appoint
somebody and give him a badge and say oh
you now go take it you can't do that
because he has the right to his stuff
his property his happiness when it comes
to guns no one if I told you a story
that this guy and he's a really nice guy
he's wonderful
everybody loved him he's Robin Williams
okay a guy no one could say anything bad
about Robin Williams right and I tell
you the story that Robin Williams went
into the woods and he was he was
tracking baby bears and he went into a
cave and he saw this cute little baby
bear and mom was sleeping over the side
and he picked up that baby bear and
here's Robin Williams just hugging and
same sweet things to this baby bear
if mob got up and killed Robin Williams
would we say that damn bear or would we
say what the hell is wrong with IRA
Williams right right natural right to
protect yourself if we can just have a
conversation about government shouldn't
spies should the government spy on
people no no those things we can connect
on that's what makes us American that's
what makes us great is that we have
natural rights and I have no right to
take that from you
I've no right to tell you how to live
your life how to conduct your life what
to believe in what not to believe in no
right no church can tell you that no
atheist can tell a church that you have
no right
let's leave each other alone not steal
each other's stuff and be good to one
another I think I finally understand
what you were drawing on the board now
10 years later I think I think I got it
so what would you say then to the people
who would say but they could say okay I
hear you
I got Liberty I got individualism I get
that but the way the system is now the
people at the top just keep getting more
and the people at the bottom keep
getting screwed how how do you reconcile
that with with real live okay so here's
the problem that I have had for the
longest time and it took somebody from
the Iying Ryan Center to which I
disagree with an R and on selfishness
okay me personally yeah I've had several
over the money yeah yeah so and I said
okay help me out because there's a
progressive movement started with there
are some people the robber barons that
strangely how come all of our libraries
and art museums are named after these
robber barons right these robber baroque
brothers fund the you know Lincoln
Center don't tell her about it right and
they're against Donald Trump yeah
everybody's are so there comes a time
when people get so rich and so powerful
George Soros and they begin to affect
policy I was with a billionaire in Texas
who will remain nameless but a name
everybody knows okay and I just moved to
Texas and he calls me up and he said hey
I want to show you a part of the
community because we were think about
building studio I want to show you part
of Texas you need to see so he took me
up his helicopter and he's showing me
this land and he owns I don't know how
many acres ok goes on and on and on and
on as far as you can see and he said
here's the airport that I just built and
see the corridor is coming through here
and this highway this little
Road this highway is actually going to
link up and that's why I built the
houses so far away because there's an
actual you know 10 lane highway that's
coming here there's nothing there and
I've already laid the fiber and bla bla
bla bla bla and as he's telling you this
I'm thinking to myself well this is how
the rich get richer because he's gone to
the government of Texas and said look
where are you going to build the
highways and if I made a case to you
that you should build it here you know
build your highway here because I'm
going to provide all this infrastructure
and so a deals made whether it's a clean
out the open dealer behind the door deal
or just through lobbyists right that I'm
paying obvious to convince you correct
somehow or another that deals being made
so they affect our lives there is no
freedom when somebody's up at the top
going hey we're going to do this so how
do you solve that the only way to solve
that because that's the real problem
when somebody else is starting to grasp
the government is to dismantle the size
of the government yeah and to bar any
influence from them they they can
contribute all they want but if there's
a quid pro quo at all over jail time
should be the worst crime you know what
I mean so is that the irony of Trump
that Trump now because this is so over
the top
I now see progressives for the first
time arguing for states rights he's only
been in office for a week and suddenly
they're going follow the president has
this much power we better get some power
back to the states this is a beautiful
thing and this goes to where we started
also about how everyone's picking a team
but you can't pick a team you have to
pick a principle because otherwise
you're just going to be arguing the
complete reverse of what you are you six
months ago so in a weird way could Trump
end up smashing some of the stuff that
you hate on the left just by doing stuff
that you don't want him to dora terry
and stuff you don't want to do from the
right only for the intellectually honest
as if progressives exist and i wrote a
book called liars now and Trump is on
the cover and so it's Hillary Clinton
and so is
so is Woodrow Wilson and Theodore
Roosevelt its book about progressives
doesn't matter what side they're on this
is their view and historically here's
how they get it
so there is a difference so many people
call themselves progressives and they're
not like the actual progressives who
know what that system is okay a
progressive into what was called in the
1940s after Roosevelt by Stuart chase
system X because communism had been
discredited and so had fascism but they
knew they wanted to have big government
so its system acts alright those people
are dangerous but the people who are
like I really care about the planet but
why yeah I really care about children
and education son why I care that the
rich don't have a double standard
believe me so I that everybody has
access not equal outcome but access so
do i if those people come together if
that is indeed the center of this
country we're going to couple with
Silicon Valley and what's happening now
with technology we're going to be the
source of freedom for more people then
the history of the world combined more
people will be free because of the true
American idea coupled with this
technology real changes forever in great
ways if we fail the world goes into
profound darkness like I can't even
imagine you yeah that's you scared the
hell out of me before then you get it
with positive and then you hear better
it a little more yet at the end all
right well we only like four minutes
left cuz you have a heart out here but I
suspect we're going to do this again one
way or another give me just one to just
wrap this whole thing up can you think
of one person in your life that you
really took from ideas that be that
we're rotting them that you got to some
clarity and someone that you just
couldn't get to two examples of that
what do you mean robbing them you know
of the ideas of progressivism we're all
this stuff or all of these ideas that
you are so against is there any one that
you really brought around that you felt
this is how you do it because that's
what people ask me all the time how do
you take someone if they're so
entrenched in these ideas how do you
actually get them out of it and is there
someone that you ever just completely
missed that you just know you're
fighting with now that you just can't
can't get no I never thought that way
maybe perhaps that's why I was so
ineffective on it I never thought that
way I will tell you that now I'm having
tremendous success but it's not me it's
a two-way street and the secret is I
think and I hate to say this because it
sounds like the opposite of it but
humility and what I mean by that is a
willingness to say yep they got me
that's wrong on that really wrong and I
felt bad you know and here's my change
and here's why and if you believe me
great if you don't then you shouldn't
trust me well let me pause it I preset
because sometimes I see you do that on
television I even so you do it a little
bit with Tucker just a couple weeks ago
and when I've seen it I said there's
almost like a knee jerk as well so glad
no one does that no one does I mean I I
do it here but but no one tells because
everyone is telling pretends they know
everything all the time right and acting
that's really dangerous yeah and that's
why I say humble because you have to be
humble enough to say I don't know I
don't know and I don't I am if I had the
answers uh boy I guess I would be
running for something I guess I don't
know yeah I mean but I don't but he
although Mars is it he's far more or
less than you are so that goes to show
about what you're talking about before
that there is right that men don't know
I'm doing the best I can so if you take
that attitude and say I'm coming unarmed
and I'm not trying to change your
opinion I just want to understand help
me help me I have found I mean you're
doing the same thing you're like okay
I'm I'm I'm finding myself in a weird
place I don't know how I got here
exactly I don't know where this is going
exactly but how can we connect you're
going to find that people are
starting to connect and it comes from
this came to me what I was sitting in
church and this is one of the things
that I don't like about I'll just take
on my face I don't like and they don't
mean it this way but it almost seems
like our goal is to get people into the
club I've got to get you baptized
I've got to get you into the waters of
repentance and then you're a member and
we're together and then we'll go find
other people what what is that no that's
not what they mean but that's the way it
comes off and sometimes people will say
you know I was kind of like your
question how do we get people in how do
we gotta change their minds well got to
be their friends so be their friend that
bothers me so much
how I were just honest how about I
really find things that I like about you
if I can and if I don't I'm not your
friend and if I find things that I like
about you I'm your friend and maybe
someday you'll go this is really a good
guy he's not the guy I thought he was
dude tell me what's up with this yeah
how about we just genuinely try to like
each other without an agenda I don't
want to change your mind maybe we'll end
up learning something on both sides
that's how you finish an interview I did
not look down once which is what I
always say this is the mark of a good
interview and of course you guys know
this already but you can find more of
Glenn at glenn beck's calm
[Music]
you